hallo mein Name ist Samira vielleicht
kennt ihr euch mich noch vielleicht auch
nicht ich war die letzten zwei Jahre
lang sehr beschäftigt mit meinem Haus
mit meinem Projekt und deswegen habt ihr
mich auch nicht mehr so oft gesehen ja
ohne viel zu reden jetzt fangen wir
einfach mal wieder an also hier haben
wir einmal die Außenanlage
hier habe ich ähm z.B marien dann habe
ich hier eine Sonnenblume ich habe
Erdbeeren ich habe Erbsen und hier z.B
ist auch ein feuchtkäfer
und hier habe ich dann auch noch ganz
viele Blumen ähm für die Bienen und
kleinen Insekte und ähm hier habe ich
auch noch mal Portulak und es wächst
hier gerade auch noch äh Wassermelone an
ja dann haben wir hier einmal mein
wunderschönes Haus das ist ein
Satteldach
das
habe ich eben alles aus Holz gebaut also
aus nachhaltigen Holz habe ich eben vom
Müll gerettet und jetzt gehen wir
einfach schon mal rein
hier einmal habe ich die Wand mit
zusammen mit Leben und bisschen
streuselputzt und ich kann mich auch
einmal zeigen wie einfach das ist also
ich habe mir hier so Leben genommen habe
es in so Muffinförmchen reingetan und
dann kann man das einfach so nass machen
und dann eben kurz drauf schmieren ein
bisschen Wasser und ist dann eben so
verputzen so dann habe ich hier auch
noch ein kleines Fensterbank die ist
auch sehr praktisch zum Beispiel hier
Kräuter trocknen will habe ich ja auch
so ein Haken wenn man einfach so dran
hängen mit der Schüssel zusammen
und ja dann habe ich jetzt zum Beispiel
auch noch das sind getrocknete Erbsen
Sträuche sage ich mal und die kann man
einfach auf die Pflanzen jetzt müssen
auf die Erdbeeren drauf tun damit äh
damit das jetzt zum Beispiel nicht wenn
man jetzt Vögeln angeknabbert wird und
z.B auch die Sonnenblumen
ja und hier nebendran haben wir auch
noch sehr tolle Nachbarn das
Ella da wohnt sie über die Sommermonate
genau wie ich die Wintermonate deswegen
ist ja auch gerade so schlimm aus weil
ab jetzt fange ich wieder an Tiere zu
wohnen weil über die Wintermonate war
ich eben nicht hier dass wir zu kalt
damit ich wieder zu meinem leiheltern
gegangen und ja
tschüss